>> Tucker: WHETHER YOU’RE
HEALTHY OR YOU’RE SICK, PRETTY
MUCH EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY IS
SUFFERING HE THINKS THAT IS
PANDEMIC BUT THERE IS BIG
EXCEPTION, AND ONE GROUP IS
THRIVING.
IN THE MASS CLOSURE OF STORES
HAS RESULTED IN PREDICTABLY A
MASSIVE SURGE IN BREAK-INS
ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORK CITY
POLICE DEPARTMENT, BURGLARIES
ARE WRAPPED 75% COMPARED TO LAST
YEAR.
ROBBERIES ARE UP 400%.
YOU ARE A CRIMINAL, WHY NOT TRY?
IT MEANS YOU WILL BE RELEASED
WITHOUT CASH BAIL.
TAMMY BRUCE ON FOX NATION JOINS
US TONIGHT, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
SOME OF ALL THE THINGS TO WORRY
ABOUT, I’M SURE PEOPLE WILL SAY
WHY SHOULD I CARE IF A BODEGA
GETS ROBBED?
I GUESS THE MUCH BIGGER CONCERN
IS WE ARE STARTING TO SEE THE
SOCIETY FRAY AND FROM THERE,
THINGS CAN MOVE REALLY QUICKLY
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THAT?
>> YES, SO I STAYED IN MANHATTAN
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND IS VERY
EERIE BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT MAKES YOU FEEL SAFE IN
MANHATTAN ESPECIALLY AS A WOMAN
IS THAT THEY WERE SO MANY PEOPLE
ON THE STREET.
THAT OF COURSE IS OVER NOW SO
THERE’S A GENERAL SENSE OF
FOREBODING WHEN YOU DO GO OUT AT
ANY POINT BECAUSE THERE IS NO
ONE AROUND, MAY BE JOGGING OR
GETTING SOME FRESH AIR WALKING
THEIR DOG BUT VERY FEW PEOPLE.
ALSO SEVERAL HUNDRED NYPD
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN STRICKEN
RATED IT AS AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
DYNAMIC SO YOU HAVE FEWER
POLICE, THE NATIONAL GUARD
COMING IN BUT IT’S GOING TO BE
MOSTLY FOR MEDICAL.
SO IN THE MIDST OF THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS, WE ALREADY HAVE
SHOP SPORTING THEMSELVES UP
ANTICIPATING THIS DYNAMIC AND
THEN YOU HAVE THE RELEASE OF NOT
JUST THE NO BAIL LAW WHICH HAS
BEEN AWFUL RELEASING CRIMINALS
WITH NO REAL REPERCUSSIONS FOR
CERTAIN KINDS OF CRIME, BUT NOW
THEY’VE GOT A LIST OF
INDIVIDUALS THEY’VE ALREADY
RELEASED ABOUT 900 FROM PEOPLE
FROM RIKERS ISLAND AND OTHER
JAILS WHO THEY FEEL ARE
PARTICULARLY AT RISK FOR THE
VIRUS.
IF YOU ARE NONVIOLENT,
NONVIOLENT PEOPLE WILL BE
RELEASED OTHERS FEWER PEOPLE
BEING SICK BUT ABC NEWS RECEIVED
A LIST.
AND THAT ACTUALLY INCLUDED
VIOLENT OFFENDERS AWAITING
TRIAL.
"THE NEW YORK POST" REPORTS ON A
63-YEAR-OLD MAN AWAITING TRIAL
FOR ATTEMPTED MURDER WAS
RELEASED BECAUSE HE MAY BE AT
HIGHER RISK.
TWO MEN INVOLVED IN AN ARMED
ROBBERY WHERE A NEW YORK POLICE
DETECTIVE WAS KILLED WERE ALSO
ON THE LIST TO BE RELEASED, SO
THEY TELL YOU THERE’S NONVIOLENT
OFFENDERS BEING RELEASED, BUT
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
FINALLY, PROSECUTORS HAD TO
INTERVENE.
SO NEW YORKERS ARE THE FIRST
VICTIMS HERE.
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH POLITICS.
I’M SURE THEY VOTED FOR MANY OF
THESE POLITICIANS WHO ARE MAKING
THESE CHOICES, AND WE ALL IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THE NATURE OF WHETHER OR
NOT WE ARE GOING TO BE SAFE
BECAUSE OF A PREVIOUS DECISION,
THE BAD POLICY DECISION THAT
BOTH ALBANY, NEW YORK, AND CUOMO
HAS MADE AS WELL AS AS WELL AS
de BLASIO.
AND WE SEE OUR LIVES KIND OF
CRUMBLING WITHIN A SOCIAL
STRUCTURE AND SAFETY FRAMEWORK
AND THAT’S THE LAST THING WE
NEED RIGHT NOW, OBVIOUSLY.
>> Tucker: IT TAKES HUNDREDS
OF YEARS TO BUILD A SOCIETY
DYSFUNCTIONAL, THIS COMPLEX,
THIS CLEAN AND ORDERLY AND HAPPY
AND IT CAN GO SOUTH REALLY FAST
AND I JUST HOPE THAT WE
APPRECIATE THAT.
CAN MAKE THEM YOU ARE BRAVE FOR